هذا المحل العنوان يختصر قصه معاناه ساجده
حتى الوصول الى الحلم هذه العربه التي
كانت تبيع عليها ساجده الماكولات الشعبيه
من رشوف من كشري من بعض يعني
الاكلات الاخرى الشعبيه ولكنها لطالما تم
محاربتها ويعني كانت تتوقف دائما عن العمل
وكانت يعني تحارب من قبل الجهات معينه
ولكنها استمرت حتى يعني اسمك محلها بالبنت
القويه
عربايه رشوف على الطريق صارت محل هذا هو
العنوان هذا ما يختصر قصتها الان ارحب
بساجده اهلا وسهلا فيك البنت القويه هي
قصتك واسم المحل ااه شو قصتك مع عربايه
الرشوف لحد ما صارت محله كيف عناتي ساجده
لو وصلتي لهذا المكان
لحظه جنان كانت همم بعد ازمه كرونه لما
خسرت وظيفتي بعد واا استمرار ثمان سنوات
بالقطاع الخاص وبسبب وجود طفل انا المعينه
الوحيده له كان لازم اعمل اشي همم بلشت من
البدايه على عربايه من صنع ايدي بالكامل
عباره عن خزانه مطر لا مو هاي العربايه
عباره عن خزانه مطبخ انا ركبت لها اعجال
وجبت همم جره الغاز اللي بالبيت والطنجره
اشتريت غاز بثمن دنانير ونزلت على الشارع
لاول مره بعدها بفتره رجعت يعني تطورت
العربيه وصلت لهذه العربايه هلا انا فعليا
من لما فتحت العربيه في يعني رجال اعمال
او ناس ملهمين كانوا مهتمين انه مشروع
كشراك ومضاربه همم وفعليه لان انا بوقتها
كنت مصره انه اختار الطريق الصعب اني بدي
افتح المحل افرح الفرح اللي انتم شفتم بقى
طب كيف دمه حاربتك بالعربي كنت دائما اروح
على مكان ما بتكون توقفي ما الاقيك موجوده
اسالك وين تكوني تقولي لي سحبوا مني
العربيه وانا هلا ما هو مبدئيا احنا عنا
بنظام امانه عمان ما عنا اي طريقه ترخيص
لاي عربي متنقله بيعتبروها شيء مخالف
للقانون وممكن تحويل للمحافظه وتحوله لقيت
تسول حتى اذا ممكن اصدمك بالمعلومه
وفي ناس برده زي ما في ناس كثير مبسوطه
وبتقول الله يقويكي في ناس ثانيه بتكره
الخير بدون اي هدف يعني همم وفعليا جربت
تركت العربايه خمس شهور ورجعت للوظيفه بس
ما قدرت وشو بتبيعي عليها كنت وكيف اقبال
الناس لحد ما هلا الزباين نفسهم اللي
كانوا يلحقوك من مكان لمكان صاروا يجوا
على محل كل موجود في هذا المكان
شويه طورت العربيه
كنت انزل بس اشوفه منسف
اكل شعبي اكله اردنيه بدويه قديمه بتتكون
من جميل
اصحاب وبصل وسمن بلدي اخر رساله بتحكيها
عن هذا المكان عن هاي العربي عن هذا المحل
عن عنوانك البنت القويه هلا ممكن الفكره
اللي انت بيوم اجت ببالك هيك و انجنيت كل
حواليك قالوا لك سيبك منها وسيبك من
هالهبل وخليك ماشي مع التيار ممكن نفسها
هاي الفكره تكون سبب انك توصل لحلم وانجاز
السي في تاعتك كلياته قبل هيك ما وصلته
ساجده موفقه يعني هاي باختصار قصه بنت من
بنات الاردن حاولت كثيرا يعني سبب تركت
عملها بسبب ازمه كورونا وبدات من الصفر
حتى يعني تجد في هذا المحل كل احلامها
يعني هي فخوره جدا وتستقبل من يريد ومن
ياكل من ساجده يعود لها دائما يعني من
العربه حتى المحل يعني قصه كفاح منذ
البدايه وتعب وجهد للوصول الى ما وصلت
اليه ساجده يعني
عنوان ست قويه
لماذا وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه بس ليش حبت
انه تسلط الضوء على هاي الفكره ست
تسليط الضوء على هذه الفكره على على موضوع
القوه في بنت اجمالا البنت الاردنيه
والبنت العربيه ليش هاي الفكره
[موسيقى]
لانه كل البنات في مجتمعنا تربوا على انهم
لما يمروا بازم لازم في رجل يشيل
المسؤوليتها لازم يتحمل قراراتها الغلط
اللي بتاخذها فانا بقول لا انه يعني زي ما
هي قررت انه مثلا يكون عندها اولاد او
تاخذ اي قرار بحياتها لازم تتحمل تشتري
لحالها والصراحه انا بحس اكبر انجازي الي
انه انا في بنات كثير اتجره او يقفوا على
عربايات بعدي احسن ما يضلوا يفكروا في
جمعيات خيريه او معونات همم او زواج غير
لائق مثلا لحتى تتهرب من مسؤوليات قرارات
حملتيها ساجده كانت مزهره النتائج اللي
تحملتيها كلها يعني ثمره تحملك للنتائج
بدون ما يدعمك اي رجل كانت كما يعني
الحمد لله انا حلمي انه هذا ابني لما يكبر
يقول امي عملت اللي ما حد عمله مشان ما
عمره ينقصني عن اي شيء عن طفل بعمري يعني
وانا عنك هذه دعوه يعني اللي تذوق ماكولات
ساجده يعني حتى تتقن الكشري الكشري المصري
والرشوف الاردني اا
برده يعني نكمل المحلات القديمه اللي لسه
بنعمل هاي الاشياء يعني هي مختصه بكل شيء
تراثي ومن هذه العربه الى هذه المحل تختصر
الكثير من احلام الفتيات في مجتمعاتنا
ربما التي لا تجد من يدعمها وهي من تدعم
نفسها وتتحمل نتائج يعني احلى منها احنا
بنشكرك انت وظيفتك
يعني بعد ما جربنا المنسف شكرا من عمان
جميل
[موسيقى]